what's up reject nation today we're
gonna watch star wars the rise of
Skywalker honest trailer nope I'm done
I'm out
no more Star Wars no more trailers but
Jon this is in the actual movie trailers
you don't care I've been let down too
many times the mystery boxes nostalgia
I'm too afraid of being hurt again but
Jon confronting fear is the destiny of
the Jedi legacy of Jedi is failure
that's not true at the height of their
powers they allow Darth Sidious to
procreate they denied Finn impose love
and allowed Karn tomorrow's shooting
script to be thrown out alright yeah
that is a failure but stormtroopers fly
now they fly now they fly now
[Music]
from Colin Trevorrow until someone saw
the book of Henry and the director I've
never seen a laddie
he couldn't not stay comes the epic
inclusion and the force awakens star
wars episode 7.5 the rise of Skywalker's
about this the last Jedi asked you to
forget everything you knew about Star
Wars so when some fans through the kind
of bit usually reserved for ethics and
games journalism Disney pen and try to
match the pieces back together in this
hollowed-out shell of a trilogy that's
missing any consistency in its plot
themes or characters unless you fill in
the blanks on Twitter read all the
novels and happen to be running some
fortnight's quads with the boys during
the crossover event the day of victim is
I found the day
the day on us
oh that's what the dead speak was
referencing fortnight just like.how
return oh cool
when we left them the resistance was
down to its last gasp and the first
order reigns supreme
now stuff has happened and the
resistance is back to fighting string
while the first order is taking loans
from the rich old Grampa they don't call
anymore they'll strike a dark bargain
with the only character left on the
rotting carcass of the original trilogy
Palpatine or a clone of them that's like
rotting away and Snoke is also a clone
in these be not super clear the Emperor
is enacting the same plan he had last
time
truly young Jedi in describing down
directly down and junk journey towards
the box strike me down and my spirit
will pass him to you and with that fails
in with the old zap hands but luckily
the same Luke Skywalker who failed in
the so mass also let the scavenger hunt
to stop him send our heroes running to
find the thingy called him a gunfighter
pop this back that leads to the other
thingy
that leads to the bad guy she's going to
exelon she's showing us how to get there
well the first order keep sending them
running whenever some character growth
is about to happen there's an incoming
destroy we gotta go now
hey that was a cool chase hey you know
I've been thinking a lot about this film
and the biggest issue has at its core is
oh no Tigers everybody's grab all the
new characters you still barely know
after three movies completing his arm
from Han Solo type to just Han Solo yeah
Finn who's still fighting against all
odds to keep himself in the movie who
snatched a metal out of Laius cold dead
hands just a place of 40 year old
fanboys these for Schmucks whose stories
must have been cut for time all read
continuing the Skywalker tradition of
being a genocide of death contest whose
redeemed by a single act of good and red
who's taken Luke's x-wing his lightsaber
his book collection possibly his
childhood home and his last name right
race time Luka huh was replaying the
long game cuz I think Luke just got
talented mrs. Ridley back the newcomers
don't worry no one is ever really gone
rejoin your old pals Threepio Chewie
Luke Leia Han and Lando who are so
sidelined at this point that one of them
is fake memory white restoration
complete were the big knives
one of them thinks last Jedi was for
fake bands only the Jedi weapon deserves
more of his fans from causing the fake
death of her son one of them died two
movies ago and is so over this franchise
he wouldn't even get a haircut to cameo
as a memory just seemingly hit on his
own daughter well it's fun though didn't
know that's who Janna was supposed to be
it was in the rise of Skywalker visual
companion his disease should have been
reading that in 30 rounds at 49 call
yourself a Stones fan so strengthen that
brings so much new to the franchise from
the new force powers they would have
really come in handy for qui-gon jinn
[Music]
to hammering it home that all these dead
stormtroopers were actually kidnap
children harvest more of a galaxy flan
to finally see the Knights of Ren do
absolutely nothing than go out like a
bunch of weak-ass bugs and mercifully
brings the new Star Wars cinematic era
to a close with a sloppily constructed
hastily executed nurse that managed to
do the impossible
unite fans who love the last Jedi and
fans who hated the West gentle bed use
the force be the only consistent
character across all nine - and r2 plus
protein trophies don't force so hard
you'll end up just like your brother an
old man wearing the same outfit he had
in his 20s the rocket here at rolling
James Dio and clothes in a cage
bland Moff Tarkin a rose by any other
name would get to speak
no arms doors sibelius you know it's
cooler than one captain phasma says
captain phasma's and rays dramatic
reveal phase yes ha ha trailer montage
and she doesn't really get star wars
episode 9 the last Star Wars for a while
at least you know I'm starting to think
it's a bad idea for get commented a
lovely bunch of coconuts there they are
all standing in a row who you calling a
cootie Queen you lent liquor I'm sorry
for peeing during be a man alright that
great job team not bad John Bailey
screen junkies team you did it again you
put together a wonderful scripts great
editing John Bailey Creed voiceover work
brought up some things I wasn't fully
aware about because a lot of it is
brought up here yeah we've talked about
so much on the channel already but I do
love your line towards the end of this
unite all the fans who loved the last
Jedi and all the fans who hated the last
Jedi by pleasing absolutely nobody
it would appear when you just go through
comments and hear social media talk
although I'll run it tomatoes it does
hold like an 86 percent of almost a
hundred thousand users on the audience
core so there's a lot of fans out there
for this movie my first time viewing and
I really did have a lot of fun with it
like I ran past all the problems all the
fun and then over the course of 24 hours
the problems just sure this is all I
feel now let's put it all on the back of
my brain and uh that's there because
yeah I mean even looking at some of the
footage here that first chase weather
hopping through in the Millennium Falcon
I think is a really great fight scene I
do enjoy the waves crashing Rey and kylo
going toe-to-toe with each other
that being said everything that's
problematic with the film that's brought
up here and more is very much true and I
also really love the bit that they did
here
you know what the real problem with
assumes auto-type fighters are coming
yes it's very true that's like the
structure of the movie is like plot plot
Oh run plot rod run one of my favorite
just little bits and pieces of this came
out of that idea that they keep
repeating stuff because the force
awakens came out I remember people being
kind of dismayed that oh it's just
another Death Star last Jedi goes out of
his way to set up some new stakes take
kylo Ren out from under somebody's thumb
and then in the very next movie we're
going back to states we've already seen
Palpatine again trying to do the same
plan
yeah and putting kylo Ren back under the
thumb of an all evil Emperor it's great
it's set up not great at sticking the
landing on things another saw the point
- you brought up about kylo Ren this man
who commits acts of genocide is suddenly
redeemed because of one single act of
kindness when you really help give rise
to a lot of what goes on in this movie
in the whole franchise aha yes when the
machines t3 the real t3 no no I'm
talking about Lando and Jana Jana Jana
and one opinion states that the visual
dictionary says the daughter was taken
she was taken but doesn't confirm that
the character and Rises Scott Walker is
Lando's daughter either way it still
reads as creepy he's only 80 years old I
bet he improvised that is how I talk to
the ladies and I will give it to them I
know I said it that r2d2 was also as
consistent but looking back r2d2
presented a lot more capabilities and
the prequels than he ever did in like
Episode four or five and six so I would
say that's an inconsistency so yeah I
would say Threepio is definitely the
most consistent and yes looking back on
it I still don't really know the
characters all that well no I don't know
them the best in the force awakens and
then it doesn't really get much deeper
than that you can kind of guess and make
your own head canada you know let's just
put some archetypes in here and go for
it well I would say the protagonists are
the problems high/low wrens easily the
best character out of this latest
trilogy and I think Daisy Ridley as much
as I thought that montage was a lot of
fun that's her Macaulay Culkin face yeah
put it in the compilation now you
totally agree was she does that face a
lot but I still think she does a great
job in the film yeah
during that montage I got caught up in
whatever she was looking at so it's like
being emotionally Juran
like that a lot but I guess it works I
want to quickly comment on the Harrison
Ford I think it's a weird cameo first
off I'm not a big fan of the trope of
ghost dad shows up to give advice when
he's not really there I don't I don't
know what the cannon says now all right
it seems to be freaking changing every
week I go on some movie news site and
some new information about roses locker
revealed in a pamphlet sunflower
generally speaking when movies do it I'm
not a fan of it because it's not real
but they're getting the perfect advice
from this delusional thing the Cameo I
find compelling for two reasons that are
both comes down to Harrison Ford
Harrison Ford simultaneously does a
great job in that scene and at the same
time he also seems like he doesn't give
a [ __ ] diagrams
he was achieving it's like perfect
because I'm watching him going you only
did this for the money I could feel it
and then the other side is doing a good
job you know yeah I mean this effective
moment and hey at least we know now the
ghosts hair continues to grow yeah so is
fortnight now part of Canada tour
tonight is canon there are a whole bunch
of new books there canon there's
probably gonna be like a sticker pack
with some new canon information on it i
just want to know if anybody has taken
in all of that since the movies coming
out I guess Star Wars has now become an
information world-building franchise as
opposed to you know characters like
Harry Potter now we're just gonna put
out tweets ah they did this and now it's
part of the story I also think it's
complete crap and that Finn was trying
to tell ray that he's force-sensitive
when he was sinking how would that work
mm-hmm all right if you're not gonna
make him gay at least stick the landing
but though he was so int array in the
force awakens it's a whole show into it
you got a boyfriend a cute boyfriend
yeah it would make more sense that you
want to tell her he loves her what makes
more sense right uh how did you tell you
something I'm in love with you or great
Oh for sighs before we die just want to
let you know we have more in common well
rise a Skywalker has a grown on you
there's no subscribe to screen junkies
subscribe to the real rejects click the
notification bug get notified whenever
got a YouTube video up and hey let's end
this with a for Daniel Gallacher okay so
I did some googling and there is an
insane amount of Daniel's Gallacher in
Scotland and so I decided to take a
tally of them and kind of list what the
different jobs are so you can see what
you have to live up to out there so one
owns a French restaurant called regime
he opened when he was 23 more than a few
Daniels Gallacher work in the fields of
oil and energy yet another is the
governor of Glasgow Caledonian
University and another the regional
manager of the Masco corporation still
another DG was a murderous pervert and
one lived in the 19th century as a poet
there's one enjoying having no job
living by the sea and there are even
some living out by Grieg at me so I have
only one more question to boot and
that's which one's the real Daniel
Gallagher and which one do I shoot
because there can only be one and if I
assume it's like love one where we you
know kill them though then you'll get
their power to shout out